imagine this like like let's just say we
didn't have crypto and we just had this
right now what'll happen is if you start
to speak out
Troy I mean basically we'd have to find
a way to donate or you have to have a
homie with you to pay for stuff for you
cuz you'd be completely out of the
system or you'd have you basically go
back to bartering well maybe the Amish
had it figured
out I mean I've seen videos of Amish gr
like literally like like doing drifting
in their cars
little TS and boogies well yeah but then
you're going to have like entire Sports
well you already have entire sports
stadiums that only take digital payments
they won't even take cash sub stadiums
anymore right